عامر بالنصف بالنسبه للسلطات الاوكرانيه
تقول انها سيطرت على رابوتينو
انها تحاول التقدم جنوب شرق البلد
نعم عثمان بالفعل هذا ما اكدته نائبه وزير
الدفاع هنمار هذه القريه هو كان حديث اصلا
من عده ايام عن سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه
عليها اليوم يعني فصلت في هذا الموضوع
مليار عندما اكدت السيطره عليها بل قالت
اننا نتحرك نحو القرى الاخرى في جنوب شرق
روبوتني طبعا اهميه هذه البلده ربما لماذا
الهجوم المضاد عثمان منذ بدايته كان يعتمد
على احد النقاط الاساسيه وهو عمل اختراق
في جهه زبروجيا نحو بريديانس لقطع الطريق
الواصل بين دومباس ومناطق سيطره روسيا في
خرسون وشبه جزيره القرم اذا استطاع كان
هذا احد اهم الاهداف الان قبل عندما كانت
اوكرانيا تستعد لهذا الهجوم المضاد قامت
القوات الروسيه بعمل ثلاث خطوط دفاعيه
لمنع هذا التقدم هذه القريه روتني تمثل خط
الدفاع الاول والاقوى وبال لاعلان
اوكرانيا سيطره على هذه البلده يعني
اختراق اوكرانيا لهذا الخط الدفاعي الاول
وبالتالي انتقالها الى الخط الثاني
والثالث اللذاني يعني كما فهمنا هم اقل
قوه من الخط الدفاعي الاول لكن طبعا هناك
تؤكد مليار بان هناك مقاومه شرسه ومعارك
مستمره في تلك المنطقه بانتظار ما سيحصل
في الايام القادمه نعلم ان هذا الهجوم
المضاد يواجه الكثير من الصعوبات والحديث
عن تقدم يعني نتحدث عن كيلو متر في كل مره
من التقدم هذا دليل على شراسه هذه المعارك
المواضيع الاخرى طبعا التي يعني مثاره هنا
في اوكرانيا اليوم هو القصف الصاروخي الذي
طال العديد من مناطق اوكرانيا
وفقا لقياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه سته
صواريخ قصف بها العديد من المناطق
الاوكرانيه لكن اربعه من هذه الصواريخ تم
اسقاطها اربعه من هذه الصواريخ اطلقت من
فرقاطه في البحر الاسود وصاروخين اطلقا
مقاتله من نوع 34 كانت تحلق في سماء خرسون
واستهدفت
القوات
الحاكم كليفري تحدث عن اصابه في العديد من
المنشات والمباني السكنيه لكن لم يتحدث عن
سقوط قتلى او جرحى جراء هذا الاستهداف على
اعتبار انه كان في اطراف المدينه اما احد
هذه الصواريخ التي انطلقت من البحر
فاستهدف مصنعا للزيوت في بولتافا في وسط
اوكرانيا هذا الهجوم اسفر عن مقتل اثنين
واصابه خمسه من الموظفين العاملين في
المناوبه الليليه في هذا المصنع وفقا
لمدير مكتب الرئيس طبعا في نفس الاطار
تحدث قبل قليل المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
عن سبب ان روسيا تستهدف اوكرانيا في
الايام الماضيه بصواريخ قليله العدد نسبيا
قال ان هذا السبب جرى امس في كييف وقبله
في اوديسا واليوم في بلدا الهدف منه هو
خلق حاله من التوتر والقلق وضرب الاقتصاد
الاوكراني وضرب النفسيه نفسيه الشعب
الاوكراني بهذه الصواريخ التي تستهدف
البنيه التحتيه واعطى مثالا على ضرب
الموانئ في اوديسا والان ضرب هذا المصنع
الكبير للزيوت في بولتافا ربما ايضا بخصوص
السفن الان تحدثت قياده عمليات الجنوب
اختم بذلك بان هناك سته سفن في حاله تاهب
قتالي في البحر الاسود الان وان احداها
يحمل اربعه صواريخ من نوع كاليبر ايضا
جاهزه للاطلاق وبالتالي هناك تحذيرات
وتحذير للجميع بالاستعداد واحتمال ان يكون
هناك قصف صاروخي من البحر